darnos versace ha
contratado contratado al menos para no
ir a un punto punto
reunimos a siete modelos de pasarela soy
modelo de pasar esto el modelo de pasar
el modelo de pasarela modelo de pasar la
modelo de pasar el modelo de pasar eso
el modelo de pasarela uno de ellos es un
mentiroso si el grupo descubre quién es
el impostor se repartirán un premio en
efectivo
si el impostor sobrevive ganará todo el
premio quién es el impostor
alguno ha firmado con una agencia
representante o algo así genial por
cuánto tiempo
casi cuatro años yo sólo pensaba soy soy
modelo soy un modelo estas personas son
preciosas son hermosas vi atada y quedé
embarazada alguna vez pensaste que quizá
hay algo más en la vida que ser muy muy
muy ridículamente atractivo cuánto miden
a unos 61 77 mide unos 66 metros unos 70
y 182 187 puntos 75 sólo quiero decir
que estoy sospechando un poco de ustedes
dos por ser tan bajas yo mido 175 y me
han echado de desfiles por ser demasiado
baja creo que depende de la pasarela que
hagas si se trata de alta costura milán
o nueva york atletas son más estrictos
hoy en día hay mucha más inclusión estoy
contenta
bueno la verdad no creo que realmente
importe la cara tampoco creo que solo
depende de tu confianza interior lo que
aportas yo creo que yo pero también hay
muchas personas que si no son
necesariamente
a los demás
el voto de los seguidores quién es el
impostor
era un poco más baja lo cual no
significa nada pero para mí eso era una
señal de alarma
[Aplausos]
buena suerte a todos
es la cara cariño es la cara cariño y
dijiste que la cara no lo importante y
si lo es darnos el ritmo que de acuerdo
absolutamente de acuerdo
mire la canceladas nuestras opiniones
pitufina puede caminar
personalmente creo que tengo la mejor
caminata vamos vamos vamos vamos vamos
vamos vamos vamos danos la actitud de
los ángeles y vibras de la agencia de
modelaje visión
no creo que mi caminata fuera la mejor
deje que los nervios me invadieron
bombo me van a quemar por esta canción
muy bien ya no es elegancia
asimismo controlado contratado al menos
para mí asombroso punto punto punto sí
me encantó hacer desfiles en cuales han
estado a mes tuve se llamaba la semana
de la moda corre bien por supuesto así
que ambos estuvimos
estuve en la semana de la moda de cornet
desfile para cinco diseñadores en
realidad cuatro porque me echaron de uno
de los desfiles de altura y yo les dije
que no era tan alta eso fue literalmente
y de las vegas así que literalmente
tenemos un centro
yoigo a la amiga modelo para macys
delilah
quería darle a saya la oportunidad puede
que no sea la típica modelo de pasarela
pero dijo que trabajó con macys y
dealers y eso es muy es casi un modelaje
geriátrico cualquiera puede hacerlo una
abuela podría caminar por esas pasarelas
así que yo estaba como genial eso es
experiencia supongo si están por allá
véanlo es que no me di cuenta de que era
modelaje de centro comercial pero si es
el mejor modelaje de centro comercial
también en lo que digo he estado en
algunas audiciones o casting para
algunas pasarelas mi casting más grande
me sorprendió un poco porque era para el
indie en día y trabajaba con mucho y
querían verme yo estaba muy emocionada
pero de nuevo probablemente no me
agendaron porque el primer show fue en
nueva york en 2017 para el deja de
hablar te creemos el último desfile que
hice fue bueno supongo que también hice
la semana de la moda esto creó el
verdadero mi último gran desfile fue
para cappa en milán y también lo creo si
gente hablar porque me voy a milán pero
en que esto se basa en un tecnicismo
porque todos parecemos tener algo de
experiencia en pasarela no quiero ser
grosero pero creo que ella es sospechosa
yo sí
iba a decir lo mismo y me siento mal es
la altura para mí ya me han echado y
mido unos 75 sin embargo tu caminata es
increíble es una locura ella necesita
ser agendada
su historia parece un poco entrecortada
y se sentía como un 'toma y dame' si hay
oportunidades para los modelos de
pasarela más bajos pero no creo que haya
muchas oportunidades y no creo que sea
un estándar todavía
cualquiera puede practicar una caminata
y hacer que se vea bien ser de unos 66
metros y hacer pasarelas es un reto
[Música]
ah
te quiero chica
por favor levanten la mano si quieres
seguir con el juego si te gusta a partir
de ahora cada vez que todos ustedes
voten por alguien que no es el impostor
la suma total del premio se reducirá
sólo quería seguir jugando porque quería
seguir jugando creo que
para mí fue realmente difícil entrar en
esta industria porque siento que todavía
tienen estándares de belleza muy blancos
está el hecho de llevar tu propio
maquillaje al set nunca voy con el
cabello natural porque tengo miedo de
que no sepan qué hacer con él he tenido
una yuxtaposición tan diferente ahora
que he tomado la decisión por mí misma
de que iba a parecer como yo misma así
que el pelo natural no es negociable
creo que hay muchas otras perspectivas
que tampoco estamos viendo cuando se
trata de la pasarela es la más
tradicional que se aferra a todas sus
viejas costumbres ser delgado es
literalmente el último en estar al día
así que no sé quién más creen que es el
impostor ya que todos los demás elegidos
seguir jugando yo ni mi misma duda se me
olvida quiénes firmaron yo he firmado
con quienes están estoy con infocus
moverse estoy con él estoy con no
management a ferrari talent y luego
tengo una gente nueva york
realmente no importa mientras entren en
la audición bien alguna experiencia fea
o alguna mala experiencia que quieran
compartir al principio cuando empecé a
hacer pasarela lo odiaba porque todos
sabemos que la paga no es buena para la
pasarela cuando estaba en tailandia me
uber para llegar a la audición luego a
casa y luego al desfile era más de lo
que ganaba por el desfile luché mucho
con el hecho de sentirme hermosa y
tratar de
tengo un ser querido que está
encarcelado igual que ha sido una de
esas situaciones en las que solo ven
fotos así que libia y por eso es que lo
pueden conseguir así que eso es lo que
me ha hecho seguir adelante es como
estoy dos ven pasar morirás literalmente
así que creo que no hay otro impostor
voy a hacer
pero ya sabes sólo quería seguir jugando
y cómo empecé competitivo
[Música]
contamos todos los votos y tenemos un
empate dakota y sasha cada una de
ustedes tiene 20 segundos para exponer
su caso como dije soy de las de gas así
que el fashion show mode es donde
comencé mi carrera me encanta el
modelaje me encanta la pasarela a pesar
de que es un desafío es esa conexión es
ese poder compartirlo con un ser querido
saben de modelado durante 4 años desde
que tenía 16 he viajado mucho para ser
modelo he estado en pekín
en tailandia e modelado con agencias en
tokio he estado en nueva york que he
estado en ciudad de méxico aquí
obviamente he estado con agencias en
miami llevo mucho tiempo en esta
industria
no
levanten la mano si quieren seguir con
el juego
si las luces son verdes significa que
eliminaron a un impostor y ganaron si la
sucesión roja significa que el impostor
sigue aquí y perdieron
[Música]
ahora el impostor puede dar un paso
adelante y revelarse en 3 2 1
no sabía que me hubiese derrotado por mí
soy yo era la masa está allí y ella era
genial y tenía una gran caminata y se ve
impresionante así que ella habría sido
mi última o penúltima elección creo que
mi altura me salvó honestamente todavía
existe esa noción preconcebida de cómo
es una modelo y creo que este episodio
realmente enfatiza que tenemos un largo
camino por recorrer definitivamente creo
que podría ser modelo pero la caminata
me pareció un poco fuera de lugar no
creí que fueras el impostor o únicamente
porque realmente creo en la gente así
que creo que mezclar el hecho de hacerlo
por un ser querido que está encarcelado
es extremadamente ofensivo así que eso
es algo que yo no no habría caído tan
bajo con eso eso es
vaya realmente si tengo un ser querido
en la cárcel solo no soy modelo pero
siento que te hayas sentido así porque
no pensé que fuera así porque en mi
mente sigue siendo tan fiel a mi
historia y a lo que soy your case y le
envío fotos a mi padre y lo mantengo al
día solo que nunca he estado en una
pasarela esa no es su historia es la
historia de su padre hay que cuidar la
forma en que hablamos sobre las personas
encarceladas yo
tomo fotos me encanta hacer sesiones de
fotos nunca me han pagado por un trabajo
lo hago porque me parece divertido he
descubierto que al tomar fotos puedo
compartirlas con mis seres queridos ha
sido nuestra forma divertida de
comunicarnos él tiene una visión del
mundo exterior y ve que estoy trabajando
así que eso fue muy cierto y no fue una
historia inventada en absoluto lo único
fue que no soy modelo de pasarela cómo
se siente al gana se siente muy bien
todavía estoy sorprendida me siento mal
ahora
qué horrible me siento muy mal
sí
ah
[Música]